لذلك
منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر ، شهدنا
ارتفاعًا ملحوظًا في
كثافة ومدى الصواريخ التي يتم
إطلاقها من غزة
على المدنيين الإسرائيليين ، نحن في عسقلان
الآن ، لكن
نطاق الصواريخ تم توسيعه ليشمل
أشدود وحتى الشمال من ذلك  لذلك نرى
أن الإرهابيين
يوسعون مداهم نحو الشمال نحن من
جانبنا قمنا بتوسيع
أنشطتنا أيضًا وضربنا
أهدافًا إضافية تنتمي إلى
حماس والجهاد الإسلامي وفقًا
للتوجيهات التي أصدرها قائد الجيش.
الفريق أول ركن أفيف
نحن نستعد لتعزيز
عملياتنا بشكل أكبر
ونرى أن حماس لا تولي أي اعتبار لأرواحنا
المدنية أو لحياة المدنيين
الفلسطينيين ونرى مرة أخرى هجومهم ضدنا
غير مقبول
تمامًا ونحن على استعداد لجعلهم يدفعون الثمن.
ثمن عدوانهم مرة أخرى
كم أه كان
بالله فالجيش الإسرائيلي نفذ أكثر من 150
ضربة
حتى أه في ساعات الظهيرة الأولى  في
الوقت
الذي قمنا فيه بأكثر من 150 غارة على
أهداف مختلفة في جميع أنحاء قطاع غزة ،
نحاول إلى أقصى حد ممكن
ضرب أهداف عسكرية فقط
ونحاول التمييز بين
المدنيين غير
المقاتلين وهؤلاء المقاتلين حتى الآن أكثر من 15
حماسًا وإسلاميًا.  لقد قُتل عناصر جهاديون
في غاراتنا وهدفنا هو
الاستمرار في
مطاردة الإرهابيين بينما نحاول
تقليل
عدد غير المقاتلين الذين
تضرروا من
الأنشطة إلى أقصى حد ممكن ، هل لديك أي تحديث بشأن
تلك التقارير عن المدنيين؟  العاصمة
بما في ذلك تسعة أطفال
قتلوا بالأمس
في هذا الوقت ، لا يمكنني أن أقول
إننا نتعامل مع كل هذه التقارير
على محمل الجد ، فهذا ليس
شيئًا نتعامل معه باستخفاف ،
لكن يمكنني القول أنه مع استمرار
وابل الصواريخ الهائل
من غزة ، نعلم  أن
معدل فشل
الصواريخ من غزة تجاه إسرائيل
مرتفع بشكل استثنائي هذه الطلقة أكثر
من ثلث الصواريخ التي
أطلقها الإرهابيون
لقد فشلوا وسقطوا في غزة ، لذلك
لا يمكن استبعاد
أن بعض الضحايا المدنيين
داخل غزة كانوا
نتيجة لإطلاق النار داخل غزة ولكن
بعد أن قلنا إننا نبذل
قصارى جهدنا لتقليل
الأضرار الجانبية في غاراتنا.
كانت هناك أي خسائر مدنية
في إسرائيل
في الصواريخ الأخيرة من هذا الصباح
لدينا تقارير عن جرحى مدنيين إسرائيليين
هنا في عسقلان في ساعات الصباح الباكر من
نفس المبنى الذي كنا
فيه وهناك إسرائيلي مصاب بجروح خطيرة
وأعتقد أن
خمسة إسرائيليين آخرين
أصيبوا و  كانت هناك تقارير عن
جرحى إسرائيليين في أشدود
وفي مكان آخر في عسقلان ، لذلك
للأسف ،
بدأنا اليوم
بخمسة
جرحى والآن نأمل أن يكون هذا
العدد منخفضًا قدر الإمكان ونأمل
ونعمل باستمرار  لجعل
معدل نجاح القبة الحديدية أعلى ما
يمكن ،
نحن فوق 90 في المائة وأعتقد أنها في حد
د EV  مصلحة الجميع أولاً وقبل كل شيء
مصلحتنا إنقاذ أرواح الإسرائيليين ولكن
الآخرين أيضًا
أن يكون معدل النجاح هذا أعلى ما
يمكن الآن هناك
أه نحن نعلم أنه
تم استدعاء 5000 جندي احتياطي ، هل لدينا أي
تحديث آخر حول أنشطة مثل ذلك
يتم استدعاء المزيد من القوات الاحتياطية ،
لذا فإن ما نعززه هو
القيادة الجنوبية
، وقدرات استخبارات فرقة غزة ،
وقدرات القوة الجوية
وقدرات الضرب ، وهذا
ما نعززه
في هذه المرحلة ، فنحن لا نتحدث عن
عمليات مختلفة نقوم
بإعدادها ونقوم بتقييم مختلف.
سيناريوهات وقد
أمرنا رئيس الأركان بإعداد
وتوسيع عملياتنا ولكن هذه
ليست المرحلة التي وصلنا إليها بعد.